well that's sort of for me out of
respect for her Enel and all he's doing
you know that I feel that you know that
that's gonna be the decision that they
will make it's the decisions got nothing
to do with me it's trust in the law and
and hopefully that they come up with the
right decision
all this continuing legal process must
make it very difficult for you to want
how difficult is it going through all of
this and having it brought up time and
time again I just think that it reopens
all the old wounds you know that's how I
feel right now but like two days now
before while this is all been going on
and knowing that I'm going to decided to
come because I feel that I must give her
Nell some support because he really
believes that he's doing the right thing
and I believe he's doing the right thing
but it's it's up to the law now that's
got nothing to do with me it's not gonna
bring my daughter back and and daily
living is just getting through the day
without her because she was so wonderful
and special and buried I loved her so
much
so it's just hard to live each day
without her it's like all the joy went
out of our life when this happened we've
heard and you've said before that you've
forgiven
Oscar Pistorius well as a Christian you
have to forgive and if you want to move
on with your own life that's the only
way you can go otherwise all the pain
that's inside you is gonna make you sick
that's what I believe that one has to
cleanse your body of oh you mustn't have
ill feelings you have to forgive that
person and move on but you don't forget
it's it's difficult to describe I think
if unless you yourself are a Christian
and that's what you believe but that's
what I believe and that's the only way
that I get through the day there's only
one person and that's God that can help
us bury - you know to get through the
day in that space that she's left behind
it's just so sad sometimes I have a good
day sometimes I have a really bad day
you both the same bear you know it's
very difficult without it and will this
decision make any difference to you well
if he could sort of magic her back into
life it would make a big difference but
it's never going to happen it's never
going to happen
so whatever way the appeal court judges
rule would it will it have an effect on
you no not really not really and just
explain why I because what the thing is
the way it's sitting at the moment why I
believe in what they're doing is the way
it's sitting at the moment is that he
killed her and he's been in jail for 11
months
and it's too short a time for taking
somebody's life and even though I don't
want to hurt him anyway
he's got to face the truth and if the
truth can come out in this way and it's
a good thing it's kind of it's it's it's
Reaver justice for Eva
she lost her life her career having a
child having a wedding having everything
and we lost her her whole life was
destroyed so it is it's sending a bad
message to the public actually
especially the women in South Africa
that you know is 11 months enough time
for killing somebody so they're gonna go
through this whole process and and I'm
happy about that but at the same time I
don't wish him any harm